When I did my mycotox test, it showed several elevated mycotoxins.
I've been following your protocol to help detox these and had my house checked.
When can I retest?
Okay, so typically I suggest if you have started a protocol of detoxification of these mycotoxins,
you've tested your home, you've done all the investigation, you possibly can.
If there was positive findings in your home, you started the remediation processes, etc.
Then I would say both six months post-started all that.
So let's say, you know, we did the mycotoxin test to keep it simple January 1st.
And we didn't get started on remediation, either internal remediation,
taking binders to pull that stuff out and key laders to pull those mycotoxins out.
And dealing with home issues, let's say you tested your home with your bathroom had mold,
and now you have a mold remediation company coming in and cleaning up your bathroom.
That's not done until the end of February.
I would say six months after that.
Give yourself some time, because if you're still exposed to mycotoxins through the end of that period
of getting your house cleaned not per se, nothing's going to really change.
Even if you're doing a lot of chelation, you're still going to have current exposure.
So I would wait typically about six months post-starting all that therapy.
And consider it your creating your house as a therapy as well.